hello everybody my name is markiplier  and welcome back to my cardigan I dug it  out of the closet to be with me during  my sick times so that I would not be  afraid and or cold in the face of the  zombie apocalypse huh somebody spilled  jam everywhere that's no good I really  goop this one Topanga and oh no oh no  he's not dead is he one more for good  measure there we go oh oh oh I don't  know what that did but I think it was  good alright so this is a quick hop and  a jump why am I here why do you guys  drip so much why are you guys so goopy  you you're just waiting in ambush  I want this that I'm leaving if I hide  he'll never get me nobody expects a  second knife main shaft they know my  nickname I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get  it now my ribs my ribs my my ribs are  nothing but weak babies before the  mighty tyrant  [Music]  you